you know at some point in time I've been
sort of thinking more and more one would
hope that there is going to be some
accounting for or at least just like the
simple realization that the President of
the United States is not acting like an
innocent person and is not acting like a
stable person and I mean even from the
right even if they will continue to
defend him as they know that will it
would be great just to get that
acknowledgement or see them acquiesce to
that simple reality but regardless of
what you think about Donald Trump's tax
policy or what he's doing on trade or
whatever we are increasingly noticing
that the behavior that is visible
publicly is not normal and the latest
exhibit in this is that Donald Trump
burst on Twitter is the best word I can
think of for it tweeting 80 times
yesterday including dozens already by
11:30 a.m. Eastern Time mostly about the
FBI impeachment disinformation and lies
in a completely uncontrolled
and irrational way mirroring the
hypomanic behavior that mental health
professional dr. John Gartner told us
about last week we've wondered about
like what is the process for Donald
Trump tweeting because we know that in
some cases he will dictate his tweets to
someone in the next room but when
there's a dozen retweets and a half-hour
or when he is sending tweet after tweet
after tweet it doesn't seem like that's
happening via dictation to someone in
the next room over it seems like this is
actually Donald Trump on his phone
like a maniac just tweeting and tweeting
and retweeting now if I were to
summarize the 80 tweets for you I it's
difficult to do but I would summarize
them as a combination of insults rumors
attacks unsubstantiated conspiracy
theories and lies maybe with some
disinformation thrown in there certainly
not presidential in any sense of the
word however it is that you describe it
so let's start digging into a little bit
of what when
yesterday by 11:30 a.m. yesterday
morning Eastern Time Donald Trump had
already tweeted or retweeted more than
30 times and it continued all day
reaching 80 tweets 80 tweets in a day I
don't pretend to be the busiest person
in the world but I am way too busy to
tweet 80 times in a day I have to find
time to make three four five tweets and
retweets in combination sometimes I
don't even have the time sometimes at
10:00 p.m. I might send one retweet out
with a comment because I'm so busy that
that's not even possible and I'm not
even really that busy this is the
President of the United States and he
tweeted 80 times yesterday now to set up
the stage for Donald Trump doing this as
you may know as you probably have heard
by now House Democrats have unveiled two
articles of impeachment which are
actually being debated right now in the
House Judiciary Committee as we produce
today's program and many of the tweets
really almost all of the tweets are in
some way related to that other than the
occasional tweet bragging about this
that or the other thing so for example
Donald Trump retweeting a post about
Democrats are running a kangaroo court
was which was posted by bong bomb
throwing congressman Jody hice which
said how House Democrats run a kangaroo
court ignore the rules untrue refused to
recognize legitimate objections untrue
and this is how it works steamroll the
minority and railroad Donald Trump this
entire impeachment has been a farce
without any semblance of fairness for a
minority or presidential response so
there are so many lies here and so many
distortions of course in general this is
not true in the sense that House
Democrats have followed the rules that
are in place some of those rules were
established by Republicans they did the
closed-door hearings correctly they've
done the public hearings correctly this
is a farce generally speaking but what
you really need to understand here is
that number one when Jody hice says
they've done this without a presidential
response Jerry Nadler invited Trump or
whoever he designates to participate
in the Judiciary Committee hearings they
turned it down and of course Republicans
said well the participation would not
have been fair because the majority
oppresses the minority do not fall for
that okay the question is have the rules
been followed because this game that
they play Democrats play it as well okay
whoever is in the minority in the house
doesn't control the agenda in the house
doesn't control the committees that's
how it works this is how the system is
designed and any time anything is going
on in the house of note you will see the
whoever is in the minority party at the
time say we are being steamrolled by the
majority this is not the way checks and
balances are supposed to work this is so
unfair so on and so forth this is the
way the game is set up if it's unfair
the entire system is unfair all the time
even when Republicans as the majority
have used the rules to quote oppress the
minority change the rules many of which
Republicans established so this is how
they distort and low information people
or just you know I'm not saying that
preservative Lee people who are just
busy living their lives making ends meet
they will see something like well it's
true I mean Trump hasn't said anything
Trump's Trump has to tweet because he
can't go in and participate he's been
invited and he's turned it down his
lawyers have been invited
they've been directed not to go and of
course this entire idea of steamrolling
the minority is a tried-and-true
complaint that whoever is in the
minority position will will use here we
have an impeachment so the stakes are
high I understand but there is nothing
unique about these complaints okay
another retweet example and don't worry
I'm not going to go through all 80
tweets like this another retweet example
from congressman Lee Zeldin who tweeted
with this disgusting impeachment charade
I mean of course it's just it's just
impeachment it's a constitutionally
enshrined and outlined mechanism with
this disgusting impeachment charade
House Democrats have proven themselves
guilty of abuse of power and obstruction
of Congress this is a new line from
Republicans last night I did a stream
when the House Judiciary was starting
the debate on impeachment debate
yesterday it was just five minute
opening
statement after opening statement this
is now a line that they are repeating
which is the Democrats handling of the
impeachment inquiry is actually the real
wrongdoing that they accused Donald
Trump of now of course it's not true the
idea of Congress obstructing Congress
it's kind of a weird concept in and of
itself but more importantly this is the
normal projection that we're used to
seeing Republicans do whatever they are
accused of they simply accuse the other
side
Democrats Obama you know whoever of
doing that exact same thing Donald Trump
also retweeting all sorts of other
far-right figures there's one guy named
tom Fitton you can google him if you're
curious and many many others but it
wasn't just read tweets yesterday and
Donald's from tweeting eighty times in
one day Trump also tweeting things
himself
for example attacks on other public
officials riddled with lies quote shifty
Schiff a totally corrupt politician made
up a horrible and fraudulent statement
read it to Congress and said those words
came from me he got caught was very
embarrassed
yet nothing happened to him for
committing this fraud he'll eventually
have to answer for this I think the only
accurate thing in that tweet is the
correct spelling of Adam shifts last
name despite being called Adam shift by
many people his last name was correctly
spelled in the tweet and that's all I
can identify that is actually accurate
shift didn't make up a statement he
wasn't caught you know embarrassed this
is another calculated strategy from
Republicans which is go after Adam
Schiff why isn't Adam Schiff here
testifying at the House Judiciary
Committee we hear that time and time
again during the Judiciary Committee
hitting hearings of course Schiff is on
the Intelligence Committee not the
Judiciary Committee when will shift
testify well why would Adam Schiff
testify in this entire thing this is
another line that Republicans and Trump
and people around Trump have been
repeated where is Adam Schiff he's
missing he won't show up he's lying he's
fabricating documents he should be
investigated and possibly punished I'm
not going to subject you to all 80 of
Donald Trump's tweets and retweets if
you're so inclined you
can review them yourself but the
highlights are lies and disinformation
this is not the behavior of an innocent
person this is not the comportment of a
stable person blame anyone but yourself
for anything you can think of and again
eighty tweets in a day including dozens
by 11:30 in the morning when you suspect
someone uses uppers and you see what
appears to be a manic hyper use of
social media certainly once again it
raises those questions about what
exactly is going on with Donald Trump
what I hope people understand is that
this is how Trump has operated his
entire adult business career blame other
people shift responsibility to somebody
else buy or coerce your way out of
problems intimidate your way out of
problems
pass the buck whenever possible count on
the justice system to work well for you
because you're rich and it usually works
very well for the rich this time
it's turning out to be a little bit
harder to get away with it because
Donald Trump is President of the United
States after all but he still might get
away with it and that's the worst part
of it eventually you know when you look
at the Hollywood movie the spoiled brat
who's mean and a bully eventually gets
held to account by the little guy by
society whatever eventually the strong
man has a downfall and the underdog or
the people or whatever get their day
right this is not a screenplay this is
real life and in real life we have two
justice systems and Donald Trump may
well end up getting away with this the
narcissistic spoiled brat who in the
movies in the great American novel
whatever right eventually when you write
the story they have consequences they
experience consequences for what they do
this is not a movie our system is not a
movie it's designed to let the rich
privileged bullies do whatever they want
and very often get away with it so that
is the unfortunate reality that we are
dealing with right now let me know your
thoughts about all of this if you've
been watching the Judiciary Committee
debate about the impeachment articles I
am on Twitter at D Pakman you can send
me a message there please follow me
there you can also if you're watching on
YouTube just leave a reply as a comment
remembering of course to like this video
as well we'll take a quick break we have
a lot to discuss today I'm glad you're
with us